c'est au collège juliette dodu à saint
denis qui a été fêté la journée de la
non-violence en présence du conseil
départemental du consulat général de
l'inde et du collectif pour
l'élimination des violences
intrafamiliales
près de 200 élèves étaient réunis dans
le gymnase du collège pour célébrer la
paix ce 2 octobre jour de naissance du
mahatma gandhi apôtre de la non violence
alors la journée de la non violence je
répète qui a été instituée par l'onu il
y a huit ans à peu près l'onu a pris
conscience que il avait vraiment
beaucoup trop de violence de part le
monde et que cette violence là ne
générait que de la queue de la douleur
de la souffrance que des deuils et
caetera et que sa porte et atteindra
l'équilibré mais la cohésion sociale et
à la santé des individus
donc il a été décidé les 193 états ont
été d'accord décidé de dire que pour une
lune de pour une bonne journée par an
sauf que c'est pas suffisant mais au
moins une journée par an et jaune est
national on allait parler justement de
la non-violence de lutter contre cette
violence aujourd'hui qui est assidue aux
équipes qui est un peu partout on le
sait voilà donc cette journée c'est pour
faire réfléchir
sensibiliser le plus large public
possible au fait que avec la violence on
n'arrive à rien avec de la non violence
on peut arriver à beaucoup de choses
après la prestation d'une des chorales
de l'école et de la lecture de plusieurs
poèmes il leur a été rappelé les
principes de la non-violence moment
symbolique de cette journée un arbre de
la paix a été plantée dans la cour du
collège par les nerfs
un moment très important pour le
principal du collège qui a récemment vu
son établissement marqué par l'agression
d'un professeur par une élève à mes
côtés je pense que c'est une action
éducative tout à fait intéressante
elle est d'autant plus pertinente que
comme vous le savez notre établissement
a subi un épisode de violences récemment
et je pense que cette journée est une
forme de réconciliation après 7
après cet épisode parfois il y à jaillir
une petite graine de 2
de militantisme de volonté de construire
la paix qui peut apparaître chez l'un ou
l'autre de ces jeunes
et puis bien entendu au delà des
discours maintenant il faut des actes